el punto a se encuentra en menos 55 es
decir estas son sus coordenadas y es el
centro del círculo y muy bien entonces
vamos a tener un círculo cuyo centro se
encuentra en menos menos 55 dice el
punto b se encuentra en 31 muy bien
tenemos un punto que se encuentra en 3.1
y es el centro del círculo b que
entonces de este punto b se encuentra en
31 y finalmente nos dice que el punto p
se encuentra en 0 0 y que está sobre voy
a ponerlo con otro color y que está
sobre los dos círculos anteriores
entonces vamos a tratar de ir graficando
esto la pregunta final que nos plantean
es cuáles de los siguientes puntos se
encuentran en el círculo a en el b o en
ambos y aquí están los puntos que nos
dan muy bien entonces vamos graficando
primero el punto a se encuentra en menos
5 aquí está el menos 5,5 vamos hasta acá
muy bien aquí está nuestro punto a que
está en el 5,0 en el menos 55 muy bien
ahí está el punto a después nos dice el
punto b se encuentra en 3.1 nos vamos al
3 que está el 3,1 aquí está nuestro
punto b muy bien y finalmente y que es
la información más importante de este
problema nos dice el punto p se
encuentra en 0 0 que es esencialmente el
origen y nos dice bueno por supuesto
aquí no puedo pintar los círculos porque
no sé qué radio tienen pero la
información más importante es justamente
esta porque nos dice que p se encuentra
en 0 0 muy bien y que se encuentra sobre
los dos círculos eso quiere decir y voy
a tratar de trazar esta línea que si yo
trazo la línea de ave
vamos a intentar hacer un mejor esfuerzo
digamos si trazamos esta línea de ave
entonces esta línea en particular puede
ser un radio de nuestro círculo muy bien
y esta distancia de este segmento nos
puede decir cuál es el radio de esta
circunferencia definida por ahí p lo
mismo podemos aplicar para el punto p
con el con el centro que es b verdad
como p está en este círculo entonces
este radio que le voy a llamar el radio
b va a ser un el radio de la
circunferencia con centro en ve muy bien
entonces vamos a ver cuánto mide cada
uno de estos radios muy bien entonces
recordemos que el radio de a al cuadrado
podemos podemos bueno por fórmula de la
distancia es simplemente como éste es
este es vamos a ponerlo así menos 5,5 y
el p 0,0 entonces la fórmula de la
distancia me dice tomate las coordenadas
x
calcula su resta que es menos 50 y
elevarlos al cuadrado
5 - la coordenada de peque 0 al cuadrado
muy bien entonces cuánto vale el radio
de a al cuadrado en realidad esto vale
menos 5 al cuadrado menos 5 al cuadrado
más 5 al cuadrado muy bien entonces el
radio de a el radio a más bien es 25 más
25 que en realidad no podemos ver como
raíz de 50 o bien dos veces 25 verdad y
esto me sirve porque la raíz de 2 pues
pues no se puede simplificar pero la
raíz de 25 si esto es 5 veces la raíz de
2 y es una expresión mucho más amigable
que la que a raíz de 50 por ejemplo
verdad y recordemos que en realidad esta
fórmula de la distancia no es más que el
teorema de pitágoras disfrazado verdad
por ejemplo si nosotros nos tomamos esta
altura voy a marcar la un poquito más
esta altura esta altura de aquí en
realidad cuánto es esta altura esto es 5
verdad esto vale 5 porque vamos desde
cero
hasta 5 y ahora cuánto vale esta base
esta base de aquí vamos desde menos 5 a
0 que es 5 oye pero tú dirás aquí
teníamos menos 5 al cuadrado pero
realmente no importa porque como estamos
elevando al cuadrado pues menos 5 al
cuadrado es lo mismo que 5 al cuadrado
es lo mismo que si yo pusiera aquí
valores absolutos verdad entonces
realmente no hay ningún problema ninguna
ninguna complicación muy bien vamos a
ver ahora qué pasa con el radio ve muy
bien entonces el radio ve el radio ve al
cuadrado es esencialmente vamos a usar
la misma fórmula aquí tenemos el 3,1 b
es igual al 3,1 muy bien entonces
nuestra distancia será 3 - 0
3 - 0 al cuadrado la distancia al
cuadrado es 3 - 0 al cuadrado
101 - 0 al cuadrado y esto quienes vamos
a hacerlo un poquito más rápido
3 - 0 al cuadrado es 9 y 1 más
no más bien 10 al es 1 así que tenemos
nueve más uno que son diez así que la
distancia este radio b es la raíz
cuadrada de 10 y esto si no lo podemos
simplificar más verdad muy bien entonces
ya tenemos todo lo necesario ahora vamos
a ver si estos puntos por ejemplo este
punto c se encuentra en alguno de los
dos cuál es la idea con gráfica mos el
punto sé que está en 4 - 2 123 aquí está
el 4 y ahora nos vamos 2 para abajo muy
bien entonces éste estará más o menos
por aquí es nuestro punto ce y vamos a
ver si está en alguno de estos dos
círculos como lo haremos pues calculamos
la distancia
y la distancia b y veremos si coincide
con estos con los radios que ya
encontramos muy bien entonces nada más
así
primero ojo podemos ver que la distancia
de sea es mucho mayor que la distancia
de peaje del radio entonces al menos así
como a primer ojo podemos decir que no
arena muy bien entonces vamos a ver si
al menos puede estar en ver cuál es la
distancia al cuadrado la distancia de
ese ave sería por la fórmula de la vista
de la distancia entre dos puntos en
realidad tenemos que se es
4 - 2 así que tendremos 4 menos 3 al
cuadrado más menos 2 -1 al cuadrado
verdad es la coordenada en hyeres menos
2 y le restamos su coordenada y nieve
que es menos 1 y esto nos va a dar que
la distancia al cuadrado es 4 menos 3
que es 1 al cuadrado y menos 2 menos uno
es menos 3 que al cuadrado es 9 así que
esto será igual a 10 por lo tanto la
distancia será igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 10 y que si coincide con nuestro
radio verdad entonces si hubiera un
círculo que pasa por p y tiene radio
este radio entonces también pasa por c
no sé no sé cómo se vería
como algo así no se vaya voy a intentar
hacerlo
más o menos más o menos así se vería al
menos un arco de este de este círculo
muy bien por supuesto aquí lo estoy
haciendo más noyes y es muy complicado
pero al menos estas dos distancias son
iguales muy bien ahora vamos a ver qué
pasa con el punto d vamos a hacerlo con
con rosa muy bien entonces ahora esta
distancia al cuadrado vamos primero a
graficar lo esto es 1 2 3 4 5 coma aquí
está el 5 y ahora vámonos a 3 hacia
arriba entonces vamos a andar como por
aquí muy bien este es nuestro punto de y
vamos a ver ahora cómo es la distancia
otra vez podemos ver que la distancia es
mucho más grande que la distancia de
peaje del radio entonces si tenemos un
candidato de alguno de los círculos para
que se encuentre sobre esos círculos es
este círculo con centro en b así que
vamos a ver cuál es la distancia al
cuadrado de de ave muy bien entonces la
distancia de aves
5 menos 35 menos 3 al cuadrado por
supuesto estoy pensando en la distancia
al cuadrado una disculpa más
3 - 13 menos 1 al cuadrado entonces la
distancia al cuadrado es esto que que es
vamos a calcular la distancia al
cuadrado es 5 menos 3 que son 2 y al
cuadrado son 4 más
3 - 1 que son 2 y al cuadrado son otros
4 así que la distancia la distancia es
la raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de 8
que lo podemos ver también con la raíz
de dos por cuatro verdad y esto nos
sirve porque la raíz de 4 es 2 y la raíz
de 2 pues no podemos calcularla así que
lo dejamos como dos veces la raíz de dos
y que crees que no fue la raíz cuadrada
de 10 verdad no fue la raíz cuadrada de
10 así que este punto no se encuentra en
el círculo b entonces vamos a ir
anotando eso entonces tenemos que este
punto el c se encuentra
vamos a ponerlo aquí está está en b
muy bien mientras que el punto de está
en ninguno ninguno que está en ninguno
ahora vamos a ver qué pasa finalmente
con el punto y muy bien vamos a ver qué
pasa con el punto y vamos a ponerlo
vamos a ponerlo con otro color vamos a
ponerlo con este naranja muy bien
entonces el punto está en menos 28
entonces esto está en menos 2 y nos
vamos a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
muy bien más o menos se encuentra por
aquí el punto es entonces otra vez a
buen ojo parece que no están en ninguno
en donde definitivamente no va a estar
es en el círculo b así que vamos a
verificar que no está en el círculo a
muy bien entonces la distancia al
cuadrado quién va a ser va a ser menos
dos menos menos cinco menos dos menos
menos cinco al cuadrado más ocho menos
cinco ocho menos cinco al cuadrado
entonces esto quién es esto será igual a
menos dos menos menos cinco en realidad
es cinco menos dos que son tres al
cuadrado
ok más ocho menos cinco son tres y
elevado al cuadrado esto nos da dos
veces nueve verdad así que la distancia
es la raíz cuadrada de dos por nueve y
que es muy agradable esto porque
tendremos tres veces la raíz de dos y
que por supuesto no coincide con cinco
veces la raíz de dos verdad así que si
tuviéramos aquí
circunferencia y debería estar dentro de
esa de ese círculo muy bien no sé no sé
exactamente cómo vaya ok esto ya fue un
muy mal dibujo pero espero se entiende
la idea muy bien entonces realmente de
estos tres puntos que nos dieron sólo
uno se encontraba en algunos de los
círculos y fue el punto c